what's up my fellow bros
that's right that's right i am inside
video game look at this ah
mom someone put me in the video game now
let's freaking do this
we're gonna play beat saber oh look at
that huh you're not so tough now are you
we're gonna play beat saber it's a game
where you have lightsabers
and hit to the tone of the beats i sure
hope none of this is copyrighted
because i would have wasted all the
hours that i spent setting this up
for some goddamn reason i thought this
was a good idea let's freaking
do this i had no time to actually play
this goddamn game
beat saber so this is my perspective
this is how it looks for me
pretty cool uh let's start did i forget
to put on my headphones
uh i found them found it no problem
oh okay that's better i'm legit so
excited to actually play it
commercial pumping i can do some pumping
okay let's freaking do it
look at this guys my saber where is it
i'm missing it i should
what the frick let's freaking do look at
it this is my perspective look at it
so you're supposed to cut you've
probably seen everyone play this game
right i don't know why i'm explaining it
look it ah
just look at it oh god damn it
i don't know why whenever i play this
ah i feel so sassy
god damn it i lost it wait i'm wearing
them the wrong way i was wearing them
guys it's not fair i didn't realize i
usually
stop i do not feel normal look at it
oh hey
i just realized i put on the perfect
shirt today
this god damn it
ah you feel that that's right
[Music]
god damn do i look as cool as i feel
cause god damn it i feel cool
did you see that
[Music]
okay all right you you get the gist that
song is kind of annoying are you still
watching
huh there it is i downloaded
none other god whichever will it be
because i knew everything would get
copyrighted so why not just play my own
song
nothing personal nothing personal kid
but i must go out oh yeah just just once
how am i supposed to do that
okay okay okay wait i'll do i'll do no
fail on that one just for the meme
come on i don't like your t-series i
don't like your t-series nothing
personal kid
[Music]
but i must go all out that's right just
just once come on
[Music]
this is such a crazy workout um
okay god damn
god damn oh
my god let's play something else
uh how about this nintendo gamecube
okay that should be easy all right let's
do this
[Music]
what the hell was that
wait again that's impossible
what the hell
okay oh is that easy
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
this is awesome
this is so satisfying i love it i know
i'm not saying anything i'm just so
focused
i don't know what to say i wish i was
killing
slicing up mario's
god damn i'm terrible is it what else do
we got
oh god
oh my god sans calm down sans this is
too strong
oh that's right
i'm the chosen one
no one has ever done this
oh
[Music]
i'm already exhausted please make it
stop
oh why am i wearing a sweater
god damn it my my exercising
that was actually cream worthy it's time
for the most important song of all time
[Music]
this is insane
i'm loosing the grip of the controllers
[Music]
hey
money
[Music]
i hope you enjoyed browse this video
if you want more don't worry it's never
happening again
setting this up smash like if you want
more of this
and i see your brows in
[Music]
do i look insane because i feel insane
jesus christ man
i guess i don't need to work out today
what